[Musique]
bienvenue à sans filtre le podcast on
parle ce qu'on veut nous inviter date si
tu perds moins douze plants cette
semaine au podcast en or et humoriste et
guillaume pineau 1 que ce port gentil
moi ça a été un podcast que j'ai adoré
faire on ne parlait tellement qu'on ne
parlait tellement d'affaires son
parcours lui était ergo st lô avant
d'être humoriste et palais l'école de
l'humour
alors son cheminement non on n'est pas à
nous parler de ses passages à mcwatters
écoute qui est un podcast québécois que
vous connaissez sans doute sinon allez
voir ce et de la foi ou est-ce qui s'est
complètement a lâché sur le podcast
on a parlé de water polo que guillaume
pineau il a joué plusieurs années
sport très bien en plaine aux affaires
alors encore une fois très belle
rencontre lyon pinault est quoi et puis
si vous aimez sans filtre pas de casque
on vous rappelle à chaque épisode dans
notre page pétrone sur lequel du contenu
exclusif donc pas et vous semble vous
abonner pardon pour nous encourager
là dessus et avoir accès à du contenu
exclusif
sinon vous pouvez suivre cette chaîne
youtube ci pour être à l'affût des
derniers podcasts à tous les mardis on
continue à drop et ça comme si c'est du
feu et que chaque bonne écoute arrête
bon podcast
[Musique]
guillon pineau salut salut les gars ça
va être le plaisir on a parlé déjà sur
le podcast avec nicolas ouellet de la
première fois qu'on s'est rencontrés toi
et moi wen au saguenay oui oui c'était
bon parce que tout temps des 35 talent
est allé faire un numéro devant genre
200 personnes mais si on m'avait dit en
350 et 700 personnes
[Musique]
quand je t'ai revu la baisse est plutôt
une cafétéria avec trente deux enfants
trente deux ans physique alors mon mari
dit que ça allait aller entre 11 et 17
ans puis je te le disais en 9 et 12 ans
il ya peut-être devant un groupe de trop
à 14 puis qui venait pas m'écouter à
sainté c'est dans cet hymne est appelée
société achetée dans le coin il me
coûter ma idée je la voyais ça lui plaît
moi j'avais pas écouté l'émission fait
engager comme fait ça lui même marché
des kim heger aucune des questions sur -
pepsico
c'était mieux comme ça tu vas et n'est
qu'à trouver les candidats savent eux
mais ça n'est pas les qualités comme ph
les power hamas est plus qu il fallait
juste quelqu'un qui parlait c'est comme
s'il regardait le soleil puisque non non
il y en a peut-être que j'étais gêné car
j'avais croisé jouera ni moi mais
ça va être sympa parce que dans le fond
de bex à lui normalement modique salam à
joigny avait écrit en fait si je m'étais
excuses à sa mort parce que j'étais
pourtant conscient que ça peut blesser
les parents oui monsieur météo des plus
c'est vous autres vous n'êtes pas il
veut si émotionnellement entre les
candidats il connaissait pas c'est
peut-être plus que mettons le spectateur
moyen mais n'empêche qu'ils étaient
détachés dessus comme une critique de
film dit il et montrent qu'ils écoutent
non plus son pote hfti et c'est pour ça
que les commentaires un nul sur internet
outil le monde qui disent tous qu'ils
pensent mais tu mets ton ombre phcg
l'écouté c'est mon meilleur ami boisset
fait que le titille d'affaires qui se
disent ça c'est vraiment plus intense
que tu le sais que c'est une vraie
personne c'est pas juste un personnage
ouais mais mais c'est un hadith et était
drôle puis quittez jamais été jamais
tomber dans le dans le mauvais goût je
pense mais c'est bien facile
non mais il ya aussi et surtout mes
temps on avait peut-être plus de lait
céréales et castets les lundi mardi
mercredi passé à musiqueplus irait moins
de cotes d'écouté puis c'était plus âgés
c'est du monde qui s'abonnent à la
chaîne mais le dimanche tu as vu vous
avez pas nier la moitié du monde qui
côtoie les autres avec des 300000
personnes qui nous excite management je
me suis adapté mais je comprends ce que
tu dis quand il dit quelque chose sur un
hamiti j'ai des amis qui lancent leur
show jijel et leurs amis qui jouent les
alouettes et piquant quand on commence à
faire des critiques et férocité cette
année de voir le jour dès midi
littéralement son corps pour son regard
année qui vient pas parler de ses genoux
qui sont fatigués jeu
chat et non mais non mais ça reste
exactement les commentaires sur quelqu
un méchant sur quelqu'un d'autre que tu
connais pas personnellement
puis des fois tu mets ton tu lis ou tu
lis quelque chose dans un journal et
écoute écoute un commentaire à radio
puis quand même temps tu fais l'exercice
de déduire qu est-ce qu est-ce que je
penserais mais si la personne qui
d'entre eux n'ose faire hostile
c'était une de mes connaissances proches
le tuer parce que des fois il est déjà
foreman qui sont son service je vais
dans des médias de masse
ah oui j -pd dicrim et puis en même
temps fou quand écrite faut pas que tu
penses sincèrement à la famille de la
personne de rejoindre plus plus large
aux dames et c'est ricky carbone mais
nous les humoristes sont un peu déphasé
parce que manet on tombe qu'on pense que
tout le monde comprenne notre montée en
tumeurs sont nés ces km à la fois la
sphère la plus fun d'ailleurs et ont
sorti un show on aime ce les humoristes
ramassant les autres a fait savoir aux
autres si c'est moins peu comme rarement
ces matières non mais oui effectivement
mais parce que vivre pour le sait où je
pense le rose ou juste prendre le temps
de décrire des dogues sur quelqu'un il
le savoir groleau disons que c'est un
hommage mais si tu fais mais cette
personne est assez important pour moi en
ce moment que je prends le temps
d'écrire et puis de me forcer à trouver
un job soit aussi si c'était de la
méchanceté gratuite où je comprends le
met et moi en ce que j'ai eu un rose
pour madère animations quand j'étais
jeune animateur associations et capoter
le dirigeant j'ai dit embêté le sang
breton égard ont pris des cinq minutes
pour que créateur de jo qui ont passé
une heure et demie deux autres c'est
chaud c'est vraiment touchant mais je
comprends qu'elle ait les jo d'hiver
comme jeudi dans le civil différemment
sa tv tués
est un peu le match aller je comprends
que ça peut être tentant chaude petits
dégâts que des personnalités publiques
mais ton nom les mérites dans mais j'ai
enlevé ses raisons mais j'ai envie ou de
gags parce que ça enlever la portion
sympathique de mon show et puis c'est
peut-être des gags plus facile mais si
je l'avais un adel qui je les retirer et
adèle la chanteuse ouais ben ouais ça
sans drapeau jusqu'à ce que je mets
trois mois qui doit beaucoup beaucoup de
monde c'est rien quant à porter
n'importe où mais clairement mettant le
mettons que je ramène le volant pas tout
le monde qui qui cache une méthode c'est
mike ward béton quand t'écoutes son
podcast un peu plus voire s'intéresse un
peu plus à lui
tu le vois que c'est un bon goal en font
tout un gars gentil le ouais sauf que
vraiment en cause monde qui pense que
c'est un truc qu bo avril mais j'ai
quand le procès est arrivé ici je suis
allé les deux journées à la cour la cgt
est allé là oui ça l'est parce qu'en
fait après la journée on n'était pas au
courant la piste est peu médiatisée par
que la page en échec que mick est tout
seul dans son coin piste et tout du
monde pour le coin opposé le fil après
s'est déroulé exactement le précieux
après -selon leur succès comme un
message
mon ancien gérant fait qu'ils aient dit
m demain mais qui est comparé le plein
dans le respect le personnel clé ou
larcher décrit août qui j'ai trouvé
tellement humain là justement parce que
quand on est allé y avait il y avait un
déficient qui était le kit ripé sur mike
qui au début l'avocate à paarl puis à
parle à la télé tu passes qui est un
skype avec la famille de jérémy
est-ce que vous m'entendez medispa nou
ka partie tout le monde a réalisé que
des punks à paris mais paul paul groves
a dit l'avocate bon des humoristes parce
qu'à penser à la fin qu'on est sortis
legault première fois il y accrochons je
fais sur une photo mais c'est tellement
paul moment mais manquaient pas droite
c'est en fait il y en a qui sont allés
dans un cubicule ou qui vont délibérer
depuis avec l'avocat il ya pris une
photo avec sa pire sortie j'ai trouvé ça
tellement gentlemen plus proche de son
public puis je crois sincèrement qu'il
ya pas d'humoristes plus travaillants
comment croire pas de job si j'ai un mot
radio bordel j'ai vu toutes ces jauges
il est tard aux barreaux si ces gars là
est tellement travail en pis mais pas un
mot qui écorche c'est tout le monde qui
aime semer les regarde le moindrement
netflix maurice américain qui monte un
show en français puis en anglais ou si
comme de carrière parallèle il
s'intitule temps parti à new york et en
floride
pis qui en fait tellement pour la relève
c'est vraiment guy andré la cause de
l'humour le plus à coeur
moi sincèrement la chose dont veulent
elles mais cette année aux déplacements
aider mais je dirais jusqu'à cette année
c'était sous écoute dont on va parler de
ce système à grande erreur j'avais fait
j'avais pas vu pendant un an et demi
jaloux parce que j'ai bu la première
fois depuis un an et demi
ouais c'est bon j'avais en fait j'avais
arrêté ou de baisser mon extrême et
nametsi l'avare et en même temps que mon
ex p
ce thème pour pascal rendre gorge trek
avait beaucoup on avait décidé les deux
d'arrêter et à la fête heures trois mois
pour salir commencé mais juste décidé
jamais recommencer plume années ben l'on
se laisse tout ce que je fais j'ai
arrêté de boire un peu pour le chic
couchepin fuit chuté en alors pas de
casque le meilleur moment pour commencer
à bord ce qui est des caméras non mais
michael cheika savard n'a cassé focus et
comme c'est un peu une idole c'est la
première fois qu'ils m'invitent puis lui
buvait des vodkas quotidiennement
pendant ma faim sauf que c'est moi qui
tourne deux podcasts lui boit un coq un
vote coco moi j'apprends en même temps
mais moi j'en ai vu 8 lui mettant quatre
étaient en salle deux ans tout le temps
d attente
tu as il s'est assis par carte lancée et
c'est le luxe d'un coup c'était bon elle
est là la technique ton extrait dans un
bar je trouvais qu'ils arrivent un peu
vécu décide à bout de ligne c'est que
j'ai découvert avec le temps c'était
tout ce qui est mais poli vi le pape
pour la traiter d'alcoolique mais il
faut que ce soit toi là dessus quand
même dommage j'aille d'envoi au jim
david hodges on le fait ensemble ça va
pas tenter l'aventuré au collège ça tu
participes et mettons à la relation
serov paris ont condamné par les
défaites en poule
oh oui mais si gênant mais on était
douze ensemble qui m'en veut paul 6-4 /
gare avec le recul si c'est entièrement
de ma faute la fin de cette relation là
aussi c'est que mogi quand j'ai commencé
à sortir avec je suis rentrée à
l'université l'âme et guide les pas bons
en anglais fait que j'ai fait de mon
cours d'ergothérapie 3 et la liste est
loin la carrière d'humour l'heure exacte
les cheveux moncofa qu'elle est un peu
sa glace moi je construis mon chrono
diversité l'ambré ce je range consacrer
à temps plein à repentigny est à
montréal que je fais mais je me trouve
limité parce que je connais juste le
membre supérieur en argot laquelle je
m'inscris en ostéo météo le 6 étant la
ville mais j'ai fait 7 ans d'études en
ostéo le pendant 6o je décide pas du
fait que je faisais de l'humour de la
cité au pij financière d'autres j'ai
pris ma retraite en 2013 d'ergo mais je
savais qu'elle allait comme étant un 10
ans sur 12 ans sa glace disponibles
étaient déjà plus on vivait comme
vraiment comme une traque de chemin de
fer on aller dans une direction mais
jamais ensemble
en bout de ligne et oui ces heures pour
quelqu'un de sûr l'install kirop lui qui
décale une relation points
maintenant c'est un travail au même
barème chief la même pas foule taille à
un mode de vie qui concorde avec la
personnalité de table en table numéro un
allez vous marier oui je me demande en
mariage puis mais il se passe que ce qui
s'est passé c'est que la demande est
tellement big d'après se sont aussi fait
un gros voyage à hawaï c'est comme si on
avait déjà fait notre lune de miel quand
le monde nous en parle en fait est déjà
le ghn bagages et on a officialisé son
ambiance en amont est heureux on n'est
pas précis rendu lopy la face qu'on ne
le sait dans le milieu artistique lactée
on est juste chez clément né commandes
monde serait le à notre âge qu'on ait
deux comme d'un des six heures fixes et
haut de forme la ligne va être le lustre
au point de ces accords ne calculait
monde est déjà rendu à trois cent six
bébés c'est chiant c'est une liste
j'espère l'exercice intellectuel le soir
église de kits envie d'attendre watch
qui t'invite paul la ligne
fort bien tous c'est le tout je connais
pas c'est celle assez difficile si c'est
exact et ami noté parce que
techniquement second en russie un des
potes personne n'a dit m
mais même que l'on a c'est mon pote les
mettons là je ne sais pas s'il ya des
familles vraiment proche et unité nous
j'avais des parties noël quand j'étais
petite ma famille mais j'ai des cousins
et cousines que j'ai pas vu depuis
quinze ans les tgv au décès d'un grand
pas mais j'ai pu me grands-parents
location fait que j'y vois pas puis je
me disais j'en ai pas comment ça peut
être bon savon invite tes cousins
cousines che non sérieux geste c'est à
quel point ce que je n'aime pas mais
j'ai tout eu le goût de leur payer comme
un rapport pour me voir mais c'est juste
c'est pas tant que ça coûte 108 4 c'est
tout cela fait que j'ai on sait pas
outre un chèque pour l'instant c'est ce
qui reste un bon départ en voyage tas de
marne non plus fort on se marie genre
dans le sud s'est fait le coup mais par
un mauvais parent voyager un peu bas
qu'ici on essaie de trouver le bon jeu
maria las vegas est allé se marier mais
le pardon et coutumes notoire c'est
mario panama mais je suis d'accord avec
toi écoute c'est vraiment pas graves
mais mets toi pour dire que
c'est aussi d'empêcher à du monde qui
voudrait être le d'être le ouais c'est
que moi ma soeur mais zélande
j'aurais voulu à et à son mariage je
peux pas juste pas y aller c'est de
prendre ces décisions là de l'expression
mariage soit le tarif damas avant avant
ou des plus que ce que tu disais c'est
que le monde reconnaissait pour sous
écoute
oui il vous demande de vous en fichez au
début je trouvais ça cool c'est parce
que ce qui s'est passé c'est que j'étais
vraiment très très en état d'ébriété
j'ai toujours tout à val di ce que je
dis faites chier tout le temps puis je
faisais michel tétu l'ofppt michel c'est
le boss de la boîte dans laquelle
j'étais celui qui était tout le temps
chez michel je me rendais chez nous dit
c'est pas que tout le monde arrêtés qui
ont écouté le podcast de kayes morin
victimes de ce parce qu'ils apprécient
mon invité à son écoute c'est l édition
black out de ce kit est trop chaud de
tirs visent la dialyse et quand mais non
encore la troisième fois que la deuxième
fois l'italie ce que te parler d'un
humoriste vétérans peut-être que tu en
prennes va probablement passer l'info
tout en souvient il voulait que je l ai
rencontré hantise maurice siegel qui
était vraiment de marbre
sans ce n'est pas je l'écouté et je
reviendrai peut m'arriver je ne
m'attendais pas à ce qu'elle est je me
suis rappelé pascal fils salimou serait
mon premier m'ont promis même pas c'est
pas comme un genre de gala mais c'est à
l'impérial a qui n'ont pas au capitole à
québec mais j'ai pas belle salle chez
invité là bas pour le grand rire comedy
club
c'est dans le fond c'est dit mariza
relève quand ça on rencontre les gens
ramassent à la pelle je croise mario
jamais dit je veux pas tu le pichichi
nous en avait dvd là mais pas rentrer et
mario jeune thessa lui puis fait du soir
ils se retournent chez eux c'est sûr je
les croise en deçà de la barre tout mais
c'est de l'homme j'ai appris qu'il faut
comme toujours que pretty woman has
donc je rencontre quelqu'un salut chez
guillaume pineau quand même c'est quand
même cassé dans le studio de musique
plus poussée au des plus que le fai
présenté au début la personne qui a une
photo avec moi je préfère un g6 qui suit
une jeune chaux sont pas chauds st pauli
en fait d'un colloque avait une estime
en majorité dans tous les genres la pire
diaries de sa vie le sortir de là et je
peux confirmer que ça irait pas dire il
est freiné les doigts l'urinoir ok mais
je sais pas j'ai cessé en même temps des
interactions salle de bain ouais c'est
pas qu'ils manquent pas mieux je
m'attendais pas à ce concert landreau
bruel mai
ah bonjour la diversité on commence je
commence mon bac altéra tueur plage est
en cours de m d'écriture de fiction puis
danse couleurs on allait en avant pour
lire un texte qu'on avait écrit sur deux
pages à chaque semaine si l'on le monde
commenté pitt ici c'est de la merde tu
te férocité pendant cinq minutes
d'autres sur ton texte et il ya du monde
pleurait en soi mais si ce n'est pas moi
je me pointe
plus je lis mon texte le genre c'est bon
c'est tout le monde tout le monde trouve
sûrement puis mon professeur c'était
neil bissoondath qui est un écrivain
bissoondath loin puis le sait quand je
suis mon texte notamment des cas - ça
restera un bon petit le profit est
d'accord aussi plus à queva l'on prend
une pause plus je m'en bat salah ben le
tda l'urinoir plein mouvement bref il
vient à côté -
plage un navire de la balle que il vient
à côté de moi puis on venait juste de
finir de parler de mon texte
pis le moment tout comme au koweït par
le silence voilà lui se tourne vers moi
qui fais belle irène vraiment bon texte
le ch n'avait pas de bonnes façons de la
situation qu'à lens arrêtée en coin par
leicester
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'on fait la
physique-chimie sa seconde à 5 chimie
physique et 4 36 60 36 ans on a notre
prof qui s'appelait françois ibrahim
je rentrais coquillages pense pas qu'ils
vont demain peut-être conducteur elle
souhaite en fait mais il ya installé une
copie lui filippis mais avec les deux
mains à 86 chf lâcher comme lui tient
pas lui il ya conscience et j'ai le plus
marqué au plus haut point noir ce qui
est onéreux que ça lui confiance en son
jardin quatre élus si ça ça vaut pas
tant pis ses culottes et un prof la paix
mais juste parce qu'il deuxième essai
pour que je continue
j'étais allé le voir que j'allais au
four électrique de ma vie on rend la
salle de bains cessé d'être un code
quantum aux urinoirs sur notre route par
les extrémités éviter un gars qui arrive
est un bon alors que le ticket longue
coiffure longueuil poivre et sel frisés
il ya une bière labatt 56 cherche la
merde y'a pas une par là même aux effets
qu il ya des pauses à temps mais quand
on y pense mais moi je ne monte jamais
de l'autre bord en ville on rit on n'est
pas capable de forer donataire quinquis
en veut il se repenche l'ogbl ramos et
même des deux banques se tremper sa
crinière s'est donné votre que si je me
rappellerai toujours d'autres aillerie
ouais mais là c'est bon j'ai vu depuis
[Rires]
mais mes deux cheveux de sa naissance
quand non en titres et les cheveux d'un
urinoir mon gars tu es trop sur ta femme
d'abord il y avait un gamin équipe c
était tellement chaud il n'était pas
unique nord il fait en bleu il est
vraiment j'en étais là comme si depuis
des années la pilule police avec la
bourse par tous ces clubs au dessus midi
bienvenue à pékin bonn camara un sourd
comme ce back to back avec ton anecdote
que top au but pendant qu'on peut
comprendre ne pas boire des fois si on
devient on les animaux non tu m'aimes
même la personne qui pourrait être la
plus c'est la plus triple agent sait
jamais comment l'alcool notre appel
par exemple il ya du monde que sa frappe
pauvres du monde qui deviennent un autre
personne complètement maussade et même
si j'estime et on je peux hommes
puisqu'ils je viens désagréable que ça
dépend de l'alcool - puis votre gauche
comme faune et puis tout le monde est le
fun mais j'ai pigé le sait maintenant
c'est surtout même maladie rare est
malade
n'importe laquelle je veux être malade
le lendemain je une borne en tête je me
sentirai pas bien fait que je beaupuy ce
roméo que samassa pasqua non votre
cousine votre connaissance que c'est un
ring la diabétiques j'étudiais ménager
des diabètes souvent oui c'est de la
blague du diabète
pourtant le porte étendard mais où est
votre quotidien moi j'aime l'aspartame
personne personne moi prendre en main
que j'ai pas eu assez je suis pas
capable de classifier mes réactions
selon l'alcool que l'on doive être
prendre parce que moi je peux vraiment
pas un adepte de forfaits probablement
que j'ai jamais faite
quelqu'un je suis rendu à prendre des
shots de forme étant je suis plus
capable de raisonner sur ma propre
situation
puis le lendemain je me rappelle romain
maintenant qu'il est comme catch up de
tequila 3 de votre copie permet une
bonne j'aurais porte attention la
prochaine fois je suis pas fan de fort
non plus posséder le coupé avec beaucoup
de coptes ces cheminots canal quand même
pas jusqu'à infliger une souffrance pour
devenir plus personne parce que j'aime
ici on n'aime pas ça c'est pierre lebeau
merloni jean jack ne sait pas si le
gardien son show man du système prend
d'un shot de jack daniel's avalé un
noyau de passer la main c'est réussite
des gars là c'est la meilleur exemple
donnent les yaggeurs je trouve que ça
passe bi jacques cailloux sa famille
jackson pages et des papilles je suis
vraiment très difficile tout ça sans
condition qui est à 25 fois plus de
papier gustatif qui est que les gens
puissent est ici ouais ouais mais ça
fait que 25 ou quatre fois oui c'est
beaucoup plus puis j'ai déjà sur la
statistique le 25 % des gens sont
disparus temps mais ouais
ce affecté difficile vraiment beaucoup
qui se mange pas je mange rien non
sérieusement j'ai j'ai de l'argent avec
tous les textures les gens mangent pas
de fruits et légumes j'ai mangé chaud
l'hiver même à tout tout en partagent
toutes mes croquis dans une phrase gérer
pacolli cuit le jeu tranquillement en se
mettant le jeu parce que c'est
insoutenable engagé aucun fruits et
légumes je mange un pool de brocoli un
petit des pommes du rj pour les carottes
gauche pour est des patates pilées il
manquerait c'est toute ma vie mais je
pense que les groupes technologiques
comme yuki ni cuivre a atteint les
quarts au plus haut point j'espère c'est
la texture plus que le gould mois exact
ans mutti jeudi fois j'essaye le 15 juin
cédait santé je me fais des potages de
metz et se passe comment ça fonctionne
la santé maintenant c'est comment qu'on
a reçu commande fait urbain puis le
pharmacien puis tout le monde pense
enseigner vers le fait que plus tu
manges de fruits légumes soient vegan ou
pas le pied plus tu mens de fruits
légumes yeux c'est fake comment tu
balances ji sérieusement je sais pas le
sit in est un miracle de dieu j'imagine
parce que j jamais bien manger de ma vie
tu spears mois le tout le monde
universitaire j'ai littéralement mangé
des toasts au beurre de pinottes trempé
dans du beurre de quick step et qui
[Musique]
n'entre en peinant d'ivoire de quick
c'est dégueulasse c'est ça qui compte
parce que j'ai un prétexte aux médias
titre cote peut que disent pas et
mouillé mais ce jusqu'à c'est comme la
tow ça reste plus qu'un peu je sais pas
mais maintenant c'est poulet riz tout le
temps quasiment c'est vraiment ce que je
fais tout le temps venu là dessus en
fait tous les places ou que je joue
c'est déjà le spectacle avions un petit
bistrot resto quelque chose autour ou
quinze jours bordel comedy club je
prends tout le temps le rap au poulet
jean salade ou je mangerai pas bien
passé quelque chose de 2019 que je me
suis mis au défi parce que le sais j'ai
panier 35 ans le gp du nord un peu plus
jeune que ça mais j'ai pas une pilule
gelé
j'ai senti l'espèce d'épaisseur de pau
qui ces gens gg panier la trentaine de
cépie sa part est lancée mais c'est
vraiment compliqué puis vu que je
connais rien et c'est justement et j'ai
la main en cuisine
le jour où les armes objets mais j'aime
pas ça j'aime pas ça je sais pas quand
on cuisine des choix limités
le gie a acheté à fait même si je sais
pas c'est une compétition à vous le mets
mon ami la fraîche en fait cela fait un
livre vivianne elle aussi pour mon
avenir j'ai acheté compris s
mais oui fait qu'on va essayer de bien
manger de l'étalon la manche est déjà
bien là le pas discuté à bien manger du
camp vendant des restos ben c'est juste
moi qui tombe limitée dans le menu pis
des dés que je vis le maul polio ou
poulet ou chicken fait à ça s'arrête
maintenant mais on est en arrive de cuba
c'est pour ça qu'ils aillent aux images
et ces mots là pour dire pour you know
[Musique]
keystone et arrivent des cubes ont opté
ou aller en étant lesté incluront
terrain tout inclus
varadero mentale et faire une excursion
à laval une autre aventure de la blonde
du sablon mais là faudrait que je
voudrais faire le 12 mai a fait il ne
veut pas laisser aucune coordonnée
ils nous ont dit eux raphaël vont nous
chercher en fait puis il arrive le cdc
la poste des vieux taxis la cause de
l'embargo effectué on était dans un
chevrolet 1955 moi je capote on rentre
dedans
le yari venaient nous chercher s'y est
engagé par l'hôtel 5000 hajiti appui
fait raphaël préfet 6,6 plantations dans
charlie fait call me tony clément s'est
uni
c'est sûrement le bon dieu s'est fait
doubler dès que c'est nécessaire
comme l'a fait à taïwan qui dit l'a fait
a dit c'est une fée de la pop il ya dix
ans et allison plomb dont tout le monde
s'appelle comme chine ou la chine qui
est là s'appelle alice young lovers rock
alice young sans vraiment en fait non il
donne des noms et américains
raphaël sais pas si loin dans la beauce
il n'est pas trop tôt ni blanc qu'est ce
qui rend plus cette taxe il a en tout
cas dans l'âme subtilement sifullah
etes-vous déjà la cub
non non parce qu'elle est menacée dé
mettons là je suis débarqué labolt et
j'ai des lunettes oakley
j'arrive il est discuté ils veulent
essayer
weeds le système louise autres mais
c'était un serveur le ticket qui vient
mois puis je sache les souliers nike et
une barre rouge les paniers sur boxing
day j'arrive là-bas mais ne guérit fikin
et souligner assez yemisi ballon et
arrêtent dont le chaînon la cia si mes
souliers a scellé mais croit on est bien
dans ses caisses c'est pourquoi je fais
ce que j'ai connu à saillé mis mon
travail dans louise premier soulier nike
qui voile non merci je dis non mayhem
les marques la beauté est allé jeter à
l'eau jim le journal a bola le doudou
johnny était énorme
moi j'ai grandi j'ai une tite camisole
en drama puis des shorts limouzy seul
système pas partant je t'ai j'achète le
prix tchicamboud de qui supportera
jamais ces deux fois mon poids mais ça
faisait je serais déjà été avancée le
marché noir qui bénéficie pas comme
coupés du monde un peu pareil encore
aujourd'hui métillon était vraiment joli
non je n'allais pas les autres non non
ça va être vous allez pouvoir poser les
vraies questions nous justement une fois
qu'on a près une heure avec tony team
poser des questions ce qui était cool
avec toi être quelqu'un de local parce
que mal et j'ai dit il l'aimé vous del
castro ou non et fbi ils ont l'air parce
que la révolution puis que l'école de la
santé gratuite mais en même temps on
pensait pas que ça allait virer
communiste puis que l'on notait tout
payer une pièce par jour non on n'aime
pas surpris mais gmail à qui ils ont
envie dans l'esport envie qu'on sert
dans l'espoir que les délégués avaient
mon âge mon ressort ma business puis te
dis un jour ça revient de rochers des
fous paraître mais toute la culture
l'histoire super importante pour ce qu
on a passé une super belle journée avec
lui
nous exprimons tellement le bateau dans
lequel faye est énorme quand même le
bateau mais dans lequel castro est
arrivé avec 82 personnes cpie non loin
des miens et je passe 22 personnes dont
82 de oui j'oublié salimou l'automne un
gain et dit tout
mais bref c'était vraiment intéressant
puis bref je vous conseille des sous
filiales et vous vous allez à laval
hetherington en herbe ngâbo ouais ouais
mais avec luis s'écoule machine moi
j'étais excité d'aller lieu je t'aime
amputé de la main rentré dans pas très
culturel un voyage si un voyage d'une
semaine tout inclus sont en forme et de
la facem et on a besoin de vacances puis
tu veux juste qu'on déconnecte et moi
mais tire une semaine au coeur de la
havane agents relais d'un café allez
voir la musique live le soir allez voir
les les cathédrales men et espagnols
puis c'est vraiment être con la crise
mais j'ai hâte sur intéressante qui nous
expliquait du tout si j'ai des amis qui
y sont allés puis qui sait trop ce
support sécuritaire parce qu'en fait
elle à la baule et les touristes sont
tellement tellement tellement importants
qu'ils veulent pas qu'ils arrivent avec
personne tu vas tu vas pas chalet pour
acheter des trucs mais sinon personne
est fatigué place à la fois qu'on m'a
recommandé c'est pas de manger la bouffe
de rue parce que il il faut re maison tu
sais pas quel l'offrande à mai mais ça
s'est uni qui nous a dit souhaiter
vivement dimanche dans la ruche magie
depuis son correct mais sûrement mais
bref c'était vraiment intéressant je
vous souhaite un bon voyage que le paca
va sortir on ressent moins revenu total
étaient les lobes recharger les
batteries
ouais avant que ça recommence je chauffe
ouais c'est c'est inexact appuyer le
fait que ma copine ou cité comme je
donne lieu artistique et les notaires de
ta télé tout queluz on est vraiment eu
on est déphasée parce qu'elle a toutes
deux jours tu n'as pas la limite à 4
heures du matin à tourner jusqu'à 6 7
ans le soir arrive à maisons et brûlé en
mangea se couchent par l'apprenti texte
parce que moi la riva maison et je ferai
five fut jamais enfermer shoot gros
spots en raclant s'était dit allez on
du 26 au 31 on a quatre jours de les
bleus on vole pas ce qu'on voulait fêter
l année par sont départis de semaine
passée jour de l'an tout seul à warri
avec les candidats daudet on est allé
avant que ça soit par commerciale qui
est le tchèque et puis on en sera après
dernière minute avec les combles un tout
inclus le juste pour pansard y laisse
cuba c'est ce qui était le plus en
termes de prix le papier on est sur un
projet de rénover notre étage d'un
duplex action
on voulait pas trop flou b mais ouais je
dis ce que tu veux faire c'est la plage
qui borde et votre coupe ça y est j'ai
pris des votes colibri pourquoi parce
que prime heures
les classes à la thur vient ici les
chocs sont exactes c'est la fin de
tournée avec fils juan fait quand même
ça fait deux ans la tournée
officiellement oise en rodage
il faut un humour comment qu'un show ça
se traine longtemps puisque c'est
vraiment des longues périodes dans le
rodage c'est long mais ça dépend aussi
de souhaiter qu'ils le tuent comme file
droit car il ya aussi rodage s'étaient
plaints les mois à venir le monde triper
dessus si on prend l'exemple et ans
julien lacroix festissimo qui est en
rodage mais toutes ces salles sont
pleines vacances avec philipp lahm année
j'ai fait j'en ai dû takamasa le groupe
phaneuf en fait non pas son rodage mais
je n'ai pas connu un écho des bulles
j'ai soldats de mes premiers à sale
passé 100 places au medley à montréal
même année quand tu es rendu at-on 13e
medley et le faut que tu ne peux plus
déjà avec l'aude et plus étaient
découragés fille quand elle disait non
j'ai ouï oui j'oubliais mais fax et ça
m'a beaucoup aidé pilote voit le parce
que l'on se rend compte en février avec
le groupe phaneuf pour enlever le terme
rodage il a fait un accueil chaleureux
de montrouge déjouer une soixantaine de
fois ai-je enlever des stocks j'en ai
rajouté j'ai mis un nouveau numéro
et encore du travail à faire dans terme
de mais une fois qu'on l'a que la date
de sa mort le même jour porte c'est
comme rentrer les scripts de donner une
date pour pouvoir arrêter d'évoluer
constamment pour un cardan fait sinon tu
veux je sois belge fait des shows c'est
bon exemple
ouais comme justement kanye west
quelques sorties life of pablo les
écoles sortie life of pablo concernaient
des articles et les plateformes de stu
mais maintenant il ya en vente une date
ou niamey tôt une autre plaie irie bi
rapporté affaires et modifier ses tracks
chalet des trucs pendant que l'album
était comme un messie quelque chose par
exemple qui est je trouve que ce moment
n'est ce pas ce que c'est quelque chose
qui s'est jamais fait en musique typique
c'est d'avoir une oeuvre qui évolue dans
le temps
musicale et il s'attend été soir à
l'album une fois qu'ils étaient imprimés
qui changera pas la patronne numérique
permet aux pilotes afin espèrent changer
le mix dentelle tourner cette scène 3
mai
mais moins ceci met toi quand tu faisais
ou des plus le piéton totale itt forme
et on tait stade du ray caprica soir et
le dimanche le maire fait le titre parce
que après dix minutes montre en soirée
peuple le tu peux voter stats très
gentil n'est le cas je reste à g en
passant oui mais en fait l'année passent
au cash quand je rentre à od l'année
passée j'avais six mille fois leur
pilule m'amener j'ai pas nier les 10000
pendant là puisque je peux faire les
soirées pop qui aiment à ce que ses
revenus dans mon cas c'est b side à la
vente c'est que oui j'ai souvent fait ce
que je regardais c'était sur mon site
phaneuf qui m'ont jamais à rades de fos
mais ses méthodes le petit champlain à
québec
ouais sur guillaume pannaud points comme
je clique le petit champlain le cheveu
les petits points et solide stable
nombre de places aux chiites à quetta a
vendu et il y en a plus de petit point
que j'écris complices mais là c est
quelqu un qui fait sa menace mon site
non debuchy et sow non-stop lequel mon
goal un peu le fasse trop le web et ses
angoisses à l'ats pascal s'est plaint de
la fois que tu contrôles pote main sauf
que c'est chiant parce que calme on
vient de voir le chou fond mais grâce à
ce que dit pas plus connu chez ba si ce
que je fais en ce moment de semer traque
ça prend juste
le petit truc qui fait pencher le
balancier pleut ça fait comme à
l'automne recon utile est ce que le tout
tout est comme sa frontière
sa cote d'avenir exact des aides - mais
mettons pour faire un parallèle le monde
mais tant qu'ils font du dj cfm par wang
qui vont par exemple sur un podcast
comme du rock guns plateforme
ouais est-ce que sous écoute histoire
poursuit ici cb pour le régime au risque
c'est ça que quand la première fois
qu'ils veulent c'est comme au caire le
team gym mettons jaeggi fourni en
première partie de mon éthique et à une
mauvaise la relève qui sort de l'école
depuis deux ans
budgété j'ai tellement dallas ou écoute
j'écris j'écris au gérant mike tournant
sous écoute j'aimerais essayer avec des
fournisseurs est bonne idée mais la dgi
étaient vraiment excités amène j'ai
vraiment hâte d'avoir notre date pas
qu'au début wi fi et mémé jogging ce
parce qu'elle accueille à des millions
mais my world boss challenge avance
excèdent souvent c'est ça c'est un gros
gros gros meubles mais oui par le
podcast recrute à tour à shiogama crise
qui écoute je vous écoute mais aucun
sens mais si vous écoutez c'est bon
c'est un peu comme nous pour nous les
humoristes un peu comme mettre en route
vers mon premier gala dans le temps ce
qui a pu se sait quoi la lafa le step
fébreau que deux comme une cinquantaine
de milles de personnes qui ont écouté
bien c'est sous écoute le lion ayant
ramené avait open mic qui est un truc
qui m'aurait aidé mais open mic c'est
quand même moins ses magies voltz et
popi jeunes en relève mais ça fait un
bout je fais seulement tout sauf un élan
qui font le monde on peut sur open mic
en tout cas pour la première année à mon
avis - 8 chou mais le monde son titre
king stress est allé loubersac ans le 28
janvier en fait le mot j'ai même pas
tapé mon émission enfin j'veux pas
encore conscients de ce que ce que c'est
mais oui il ya des petits jours
stressants quantité de numéros pour la
télé ça reste ça reste c'est pièce vous
écoute mettant ci-dessus genre s'il le
faut qu'il faut choix bon non mais c'est
ça les fans de son écoute puis c'est la
première fois qu'il va aussi au bordel
tel âge
avant le podcast ou un peu comme quand
tu arrives ici c'est ce que mike qui
fait kiffer et ce quelque chose c'est
que tu veux parler ou tué plus de monde
car il a été déçu parfum métiers y passe
et chapeaux de roue le mont premiers pas
de casque on parle de métier et bagasse
le pas en voyait ta famille a hanté par
un non non mais aussi à la moye jamais
jamais je n'ai pas partagées sur ma page
non oui c'était quand même j'étais
encore jeune et où le taux d'acide bas
je l'assumé pas je la sens km j'avais de
la pas de case mike ward
je pense que d'ici 2050 d'autres groupes
comme un accès aux podcasts qui oppose
leur disent ceci amène mais quand même
mais
non et ça va être vraiment beaucoup sous
écoute puis une bonne plateforme cast
salade est rien mais le buy it ces
scouts avaient dit don t comme déjà une
chance qu'un bal mais jean marc est pas
nul mais c'est drôle parce que y'a du
monde ce qu'ils écoutent
je ressens quand des messages des fois
t'es dessus titre a finalement fixé
ça fait deux ça fait trois ans
sérieusement parce que c'est un avril
2005 pas mal moins connu que le lot 6
mois ben ouais je pense pas qu'au nul
mais je vais vous en face à sochaux
samedi soir
et moi j'ai eu mille abonnés à quel
point je préconise colombie un come-back
attaque comme carmen cat accepte de
mentir un peu au public
gers au talent message this fall au bac
ce non-match expliqué baklouti mais
j'étais tram et la bonne étape à 3000
abonnements mais moi je me rappelle ça
me faisait tellement rire mais ton j'ai
vu une touriste lancement d'amundi group
double lp daudet bâle i phone story pts
et comme le dit que la chance lui
d'afficher plus intègres connaissent mon
genre je te voyais apparaître dans tout
ce qui est utile à l'aube à iverson du
monde qui m'écrivent parce que tu sur le
chaudron des plus mais moi c'est un show
à vrak tv
halte à cloner légèrement tordu je le
dis c'est comme ma phrase ligne pas ça
me fait rire de le fatiguer le monde en
plus il dit même quand après des choses
le montrent pas de multi ça me fait rire
pour écrire pour monsieur en fait qui
m'a écrit le temps il ya quatre photos
le titre comprend l'exposent pose mon
public se méfie c'est fatigant il
faudrait trouver ça drôle chez au
premier show au premier jour de à lire
sur saône
je m'excuse et argile madické mais pas
ce que je disais guillaume naud point
qu'aujourd'hui je vois je vois pas
plaquer mon soutien
[Musique]
sa maman et moi je me sens crety mettons
jamais je demanderai quelqu'un qui vient
ici et l'autre pour tim tagi quand tu
recrutes et que je ne demande pas mais
moi je les fais une fois le
et puis il va même pas demandé mon état
d'âme on s'est fait hacker mais cris
mensah a pas de sujet juste et puis gb -
for work in amis mais j'ai juste à
grippe mais des fois ça fait de dire on
peut s'entraider mémoire chaussures
fatiguant le monde sait j'avais parlé
avec catherine le bâcle et puis elle
m'avait dit si tu le sais car le monde
vienne s'est filmée puis veulent juste
soit dans votre truc que oui tags et
puis j'étais quand même assez long mais
ça me faisait me filmer des mecs avec
rayman et soit 10 coups et on estime me
rappelle posté à ce passé si c'était des
mines quand je mettais les mym pour
milan méthamphétamine
c'est ce que tu avais écrit l'égayer
vite en christ avait fait un même
l'émission était pas fini pistes --un
mine de l'émission que j'étais en train
d'armer toutes les masses buts est muet
au stock ça s'est passé de positif
j'attendais des feux l'attendait pour le
gagner parce que je veux pas laisser
partir un si j'essaye mettant les punchs
part ça t'amène pas aux lames en effet
des espions mime way maison on parlait
on lui un coriace un podcast inquiet
puis lucien me my way sa maîtrise les
mines puis il connaît bien la culture du
mil mois ci puis plus ça va on dirait
dans le temps notre société d'entraidé
des jeunes adultes
34 des mimes ça devient comme s'il sait
que ce même forme ça d'une sous culture
du web l'inconnu pis le monde moi avant
de me coucher sur imagery mgr
d'applications mais je vais avoir des
galeries demi je m y en a 50 juste avant
le coucher je regarde cela depuis que on
a fait un beau casse avec mark fields
qui nous a parlé de chemin en mars
c'est lui qui a donné l'application qui
s'appelle floch ne fait qu'aller les
écrans d'ordinateur et le cellulaire sa
coupe la lumière devient le fait parce
que la ligue arabe à l'indicateur vous
quittez le jour exact la mélatonine
embarque pop et de jazz exactement mais
ce chemin est fait depuis que j'ai ça
est-ce que je dors mieux je sais pas
mais je croque nature qui me mine parce
que c'est ledro d'arafat abbas a su
l'actuel breuil baroin devance une façon
de suivre l'actualité mais ses proches
du soleil à style com mais il ya tout le
temps où la culture for like puis du
monde qui engagent des dérobades 200
métiers mettant leur box moi c'est ça
qu'ils ont fait ils ont engagé des
doutes qui ont fait des mimes avec la
photo est l'ayant fait partager sa part
des cidres au groupe le monde se sont
remis s'arrête un boss des le film doit
l'écouter c'est hallucinant hommes
playboy box challenge tendance parle de
saint-louis parnac dumont qui conçut un
chemin conduit leur shore les yeux
bandés sont couverts sens inverse à quel
point il faut traiter comme la parole de
la police jean alesi j'aurais jamais cru
avoir à dire ça dans ma carrière mais
s'il vous plaît ne conduisez pas les
yeux bandés
ça n'a aucun sens mais il y avait
toujours dit chen dans même tamani stèle
élèves
c'était comme si tu mettais les élèves
dans un un verbe c'était beau de faire
des lèvres comme kylie jenner je me suis
dit moi ça s'appelait seulement que rien
dans qu'amateur montpellier s'est
gonflée l'élève puis j'avais la phase
aller le ch a reconduit platoon sochaux
le sida à waukesha qu'on dit seul ouais
mais aussi du monde qui ont mangé des
tubes pour même d'un ton a baissé
il demande le retarder mais il ya une
fille qui est carrément ce point c'est
un challenge mais cette école legault
voulait prouver qu'ils aiment tant se
tirer une balle dans un dictionnaire
les dictionnaires à l'arrêter la balle
piquée mal à sa blonde et le tir et
rollins john ont repris le mini larousse
de poche mais c'est la fille geste
irresponsable
je pense qu'il est mort à denis lévesque
le de potence la haye le soutenons c'est
une fille qui va expliquer que sa mère
est mort l'histoire est vraiment triste
ça essaie de nuire à la cause que le
monde quitte ea los et coloris dix ans
puis d'enfants ce qui s'est passé c'est
que le gars il y avait demandé à la
madame de mettre une pomme sa pente
puis il y avait jose comme l'ancien h
roulant son couteau la fille qui est
allé sa mère le maître une pomme sa
taille tomates lancé un couteau tu vas
voir je suis bon type il était chaud les
ferments il en fait depuis l'histoire
savez comment ça finit mais en fait
c'est qu'il y aura quatre invités talend
nuls avec ma blonde
ma blonde a fait la voix puis tvix tvi
il est invité par le monde la voix pour
com ou ses enfants qui puis parce que ma
blonde et d'incroyables pied magnifique
mais on aura quelque chose de tordu et
bisexuels
non mais j'en le sujet juste avant ma
blonde c'était comme eux
1 go qui venaient se battre pour les
droits de son [ __ ] laveur mais ces
animaux cie mousse il voulait que nîmes
où ça y est c'est comme s'il voulait non
mes enfants en fait le tout il connaît
nos mots sont durs à nancy langat qu'on
parle de nîmes au scrabble est allé
visiter le refuge ni mosquée mais la
foule me rappelle pas ce que c'était
quand même
après il y en a bien finir son entrevue
placé comme après la pause ni moss
placer un gun enfants il y avait un
[ __ ] laveur le déclin qui le lion
enlever son [ __ ] laveur le nîmois cette
année mourir dans une autre place c'est
triste le guetteur est vaste et mettez
ces deux affaires qui ont rien à voir il
ya un bureau la voie puis nîmes où ce
mois ci mais c'est souvent des sujets
abracadabrant ouais ben 10 avant son
aventure au complet sur un magnifique
but c'est un stick cette avance paniquer
alors de vérité on était en été quand
les sma fatigués les finalistes mais on
n'avait pas gagné
c'est plate à contre-tendance almas ils
vous ont amené à od plus non non non
mais cette année on le change un des
cadors qui avait pas tout le monde
c'était inacceptable car plus en plus
sain
on arrive sur le plateau après la finale
peloton
on vient de perdre le titre peu importe
si on s'attendait ou pas ça change rien
et une paire de l'été là on arrive là
puis marina bastarache a à nous regarde
les deux cafés et là vous avez pas mes
mails je vous ai tellement bâché par
émission l'ont fait genre moi j'ai pas
besoin de ça en ce moment là dit jean
nirina mère m'a volé je pense qu'elle
voulait être comme
ça serait pas senti coupable de pas
voulu - mais on arrive la première
affaire quand je fais quand même c'est
juste que pour tout le monde
c'est un divertissement de ces drones et
couteaux des personnes
mais pour les participants c'est comme
la plus grande épreuve que fais tu de ta
vie c'est stressant plus là où il y va
depuis l'annoncé qui gagne je comprends
la stresser même justin et nous on a
reçu les garnier puis il était aussi
deux du cadavre comme on comprend post
est déconnecté de la vie complètement
c'était vraiment je n'ai pas fait on
arrive le lendemain
en vérité ils sont déjà fatigués pitié
on est à fleur de peau pel pays
annoncent qu'ils sont qui sont ratons
laveurs et un mort avant qui viennent à
rodez plage le ton berthier cité ce cas
là les yeux pleins d'eau et coop et
s'apparente pour le saas que nous c'est
clair ça déplaisant de stature de retour
et on attend la whey belle façon il sait
pas bien et un espace qui se vidait les
cas la campagne et le matin et la veille
avec un fichier ses intestins cela mais
est ce qu on est là parce qu'en parler
de nîmes une grosse parenthèse mais
wayne mais donner 20 qui est fort à
tabanac ouais parce que capable et
pertinents dans toutes ces d'un
personnage capable de discuter de toutes
ces sujets là chaque jour il ya quatre
sujets complètement rindom parce que je
trouve tout ce qu'il ya aucun fou rire
les affaires se grenu cette femme avec
37 fracture handicapées du beau du corps
humoriste mais aussi lesbiennes les
bisexuels à moi qui suis comme toi mon
gars c'est quoi le titre que tout moi je
me rappelle pas ce que ces jeunes filles
qui vient de saint-hyacinthe qui fait de
l'humour qui est en chaise roulante
parce que la dystrophie musculaire je
pense je suis pas trop mais meehan le
petit corps et bleu s'étaient du groupe
les commerçants non là comme tout
mais ça me faisait sa poche un deuxième
degré alors jamais guéri c'est lui et
sait cependant c'est sérieux puis c'est
sa job c'est ce puits mais c'est
vraiment un
c'est vraiment d'amener ça pour le
chocolat pour le oui mais tu as connaît
cette fille là avec 37 facture et
lesbiennes en chaise roulante et on a
fait le monde a fait le monsieur fait de
s'inscrire l'humour piétons
ben moi j'ai pas eu la chance d'avoir un
choletais g mais je sais qu'à ses
propres images and men soirée aux
haricots saint-hyacinthe puis au
complexe mais promis les haricots les
haricots qui j'ai vu mais j'ai vu
bernard d'amis ce mois là bas c'est du
baril
il retourne en supplémentaires et des
cas en ce que c'est car à cette place-là
piégé jeanne m j'anime une soirée du
moulin pendant cinq six ans si je les
léguer à mathieu peur ça va encore mais
bref elle s'était réservé le zaricot pas
l'avait fait son show elle aussi mais
tout le temps au courant qu'un humoriste
se réserve la salle je veux pas empêcher
le bac je peux pas empêcher le monde de
faire du monde c'est juste que moi fait
quand il ya la portion sphère du booking
jacquot n'est pas fait que c'est plate
mais je pose des voies bien faire un
quinze minutes montchaude si je peux pas
passer c'est difficile ils ont fait
descendre du monde de montréal ou de
québec pour nous faire le show parce que
sont frileux quand même les gens pour
nous mon spectacle d'humour à
saint-hyacinthe
je trouve avec les quartiers de la
relève si jamais quelqu'un me le bail
qui a pas fait l'école de l'humour mais
dont je pense je pense qu'après des
cours du soir qui là bas mais juste
comme je dis j'ai pour eux c'est juste
que c'est une fille de la même ville que
mots puis moi je connais pas plus que
toi le tap a fait l'école non plus non
pis at&t bonheur humain n'en faut mais à
la base
à la base il s'agissait de la fin j'ai
été pris puis ça m'a affecté plus que je
pense et puis j'en ai justement en route
doit en premier galette harvey jeu là
c'est en 2009 j'étais refusé j'aimerais
essayer par 2011 j'ai fait l'émission de
télé en route puis s'est luxé à partie
mais pendant pendant longtemps le jt a
marre de te mets en 2009 c'était ta vie
tu finis d'un parcours scolaire
non c'est en 2009 en fait c'est du faux
kovalev a aujourd'hui été refusé l école
helmo puis quand je lis eu le lendemain
j'ai appelé l'école d'ostéopathie hockey
le collège était de ces pratiques de
montréal j'ai fait et vous de la place
quand de sa convention fait le programme
commence la semaine prochaine puis j'ai
dit belge petit m'inscris chantant vie
en fait d'un chèque pour nous payer
je suis rentré puis c'est vrai c'est que
j'abandonne a rien fait
aussitôt j'ai commencé je peux pas
abandonner j'ai fait un bep les cheveux
mais ces cinq ans d'études en a deux
cliniques copie finale a pas longtemps
devant moi j'ai fini le officiellement
j'ai eu mon diplôme le 3 juin 2010
c'est tellement long - bougent pas assez
que l'ostéopathie c'était genre une date
d'audience un peu comme les
l'homéopathie sisters ulfar machine mais
s'il veut passer ben moi je trouve rex
en cours appliqué si j'ai eu 5 à
l'anatomie des techniques tout ce puits
non y ait un meilleur destin aux pattes
classe et ça ça m'a c'est là dessus
qu'ils travaillent fort le procès
d'avoir puisque justement quand ils
m'ont m un ordre les écoles bidon va
tomber parce que oui il y en a quelques
unes en ostéopathie méthylé deux gros
collage à montréal c'est le coq le
collège ostéopathique québec qui corrige
d'études ostéopathique de montréal qui
le coc2 l'asse les deux grands collèges
de meilhan nac exemple c'est au tour je
pas brimer les autres si jamais il ya
des as tu m'écoutes qui apparaît de ces
écoles mais je sais que déclarait geste
est au plus bas 3 1 vous êtes assez haut
et puis je trouve ça n'a pas de bon sens
pas je sais que maintenant le pharma
chimie il compte mettons la création
d'un ordre des naturopathes ouais parce
que mettons si tu prend quelque chose
qui est plus de preuves scientifiques et
ça fonctionne
le 6 mai un ordre c'est comme ça
légitimise la patente points qui
s'adonnent espèce de faux sentiment que
si les jeans mais je suis d'accord sur
la carte cela prend plus de preuves
scientifiques mais c'est pour souci que
mais dont le tous les étudiants de notre
collège puis du parce que je suis papa
je peux vous parler pour le coq mais le
ceo si on finit s'il fallait faire une
taille humaine nice est d'amener un
petit peu d'études scientifiques pour
former regarder ont réussi à faire et
que tu es en quatrième année de surville
de tes ratures aussi voici de prouver un
peu moi j'avais faite sur la dépression
puis j'ai essayé de voir si d'autres je
faisais juste voir si d'autres
traitements que la médication pour aider
d'une les symptômes
oui oui je vais trouver qui est juste
l'accepter physique
voyons la thérapie manuelle venez aider
aussi que j'ai fait mais peut-être que
la stopper
ça veut pas dire que oui mais c'est
enfin une étude plus approfondie après
c'est là dessus mais bref 6e mais oui
maurice que si je tombe en amour il est
au passé parce que je me suis barré le
coup en plongeant c'est agnès zoug et
puis j'aime bien rien qui met des
physios ça m'a pas aidé j'ai étudié en
ergols chez comme je ferai pas les
exercices que je donne à mes clients de
la façon que mon coup de barre et une
fois filmée ton en mettant camp condé
mal rapidement la différence entre ergo
physio pirro ostéo en fait si je peux je
peux être le porte-étendard de ça mais
je veux dire mettons ergo ergos et je
vraiment ramener la personne à être
autonome c'est la réhabilitation pour
que les récentes sont autonomes
si on travaille les personnes âgées on
adapte la maison montre avec quelqu'un
mais temps de tournage s'était planté
donner des exercices mais c'étaient des
exercices fonctionnaires n'inquiète pas
des élastiques pour le jim plaît c'est
ça va être comme richie pour prendre une
tangente en armant quelque chose pour
travailler là la mobilité ton épaule
c'est tous des exercices fonctionnel en
physio ses rangs des exercices comme
visée que beaucoup de thérapie manuelle
ok puis en ergols moi on était
spécialisé sur une clinique de la main
du bras de la tva thérapie manuelle sur
le bras mais ailleurs je pouvais pas si
quelqu'un a mal au dos mais je donnais
des exercices seulement tout étudié cinq
ans pour ses ergots ceux qui le croient
amegee le pas pressé j'ai étudié c'est
le seul et je me sens très limité j'ai
fait mon cours de d'ostéo pourra prendre
corps au grand complet mais en est et où
tu vas apprendre toutes les faces ya
tout les organes internes ou city pour
justement aider à relâcher sur pitts
peut aider la digestion du [ __ ] plein de
trucs je suis excédé seul immigrants de
toutes les autres grands jets après
entre était il ya une portion qui
ressemblera physio mais où que c'est
pousser plus loin ce qu'on apprend tous
les organes internes aussi toutes les
attaches toutes les l'effaceur par des
otites spa vont mal at-on coude mais sa
part de ton épaules de sa part de ton
d'observateurs dorsale cette méthode que
tu vas se trouvait plus la cause du
problème qui est traité le problème
c'est comme jouer à la défense passées
au fioul quiero bain
j'ai lu longtemps des a priori contre
les kilos mais en fait qui rochelais que
ça craquait beaucoup plus tôt tu piques
enfin comme ce composant noter aussi
qu'on intègre notre traitement mais tant
qu'il va craquer une vertèbre
l'impression d'aller travailler autour
on valoir chez de la musculation c'est
d'intégrer notre n'a pas dans jeter
crack depuis une semaine après être
venue de ton mussbach continent de syrie
est un peu comme un arbre qui est croche
pied le tir et puis ça le ramène tout le
temps parce qu'un câble était déçu mais
dont on le place droit on relâche le cam
en place un tutorat c'est un peu sur la
différence entre 2 me il yad'excellents
chiroleu ti mais j'ai travaillé dans
cliniques privées puis je voyais du
monde qui venait mob qui je fais comme
assez n'aura-t-on quiros a paré le tir
comme tu es tout roland chez je vois
travailler autour de ce qui a fait le
programme en ce qui te tombent dans le
fond ouais mais même les mêmes les
médecins et d'avoir un bon médecin pour
avoir un investissement ouais parce que
c'est parce que je pense que les chiros
ont fait mauvaise prise dans le temps où
il disait il faut savoir être trois
quatre fois semaine puis jetée craque
puis ces gens ça dure cinq minutes
kaka colonnes se retourne chez vous et
écoutez 50 pièces je sais ce que c'est
que ces de 10 cliniques privées c'est
pas comme aller chez le médecin ou est
ce que tu es une assurance factice se
ressemblent mais là s'il ya des
assurances qui finance privée et les
assurances qui payent pour le chiro
parce que souvent c'est plus monté comme
un business qui aimait tant un médecin
mais moi j'en avais fait ce qui est
peut-être que les gens sont plus
suspicieux - exemple mais si j'ai des
amis leksand schiro puis on excellent
mais on sait qu'à maurice car c'est
devenu plus business que neyret des le
monde nouveau la santé que je l'aimé pas
ce métier si ces fouilles à des
mauvaises ostéo des mauvais qui
rouleront au zerg au pays des mauvais
physio et à l'opposé des excédents avant
tout il a tout simplement arrêté de
pratiquer ou de pratiquer une photo
quand j'ai arrêté complètement à
l'occasion des référés à une de mes
amies
ostéo en fait qui est mon ostéo à moi
aussi avec lui j'ai étudié josiane shrek
c'est la meilleure note l'has les gens
jusqu'à récemment tout en faisant comme
encore je pense qu'en tentant non bg
sincèrement j'ai arrêté le 14 avril 2010
est modique et m
je veux toujours me rappeler d'avoir
écrit un email pour mincir points
techniques mais là il avait avisé les
clients type ge avait transféré le
dossier
mais moi je voulais c'est le jeu ma lens
pour le mail on tente comme eu deux vies
parallèles
trois vies parallèles parce que
maintenant je faisais ergo ergo je serai
temps plein je faisais mon court temps
partiel puis je faisais mon pénis bien
foule
est-ce que ce que tend à nous retirer
maintenant on entend dans ton humour est
ce qui te retirer de ces expériences le
gramme à ce qu'ils étaient on n'a pas
remarqué que nicolas ont parlé des thés
du du moule si on veut le tuer écoles de
l'humour si les mêmes professeurs et
même si le même apprentissage de venir
d'un autre milieu qu'on le pense que
tout ça ouais cette référence le kindle
mais souvent ce que l'on dit fonds créés
mais pour pascal à l'école le motive à
apprendre comment écrire les procédés
comme un cri delumeau pis moi regarder
puissent consommer mais il n'y a rien
comme aller sur le terrain python lente
et puis la série pu voir qu'est-ce qui
ferrait pu voir qu'est-ce que toi et
bien à faire piquer ferrer légère parce
que l'école peut justement mettre dans
un moule ça dépend mais je sais qu'il ya
du monde que je connais qui sont rentrés
à l'école pour d apprendre ce qui
faisait camboulives quand il sort de
l'école pas et recommencent à face que
c'est ce petit jeu n'est pas la
vecquerie le roi qui a fait l'école
pendant que mauges été refusée on était
dans la même année si on avait été pris
on arrêtait les deux ensemble il me dit
une chance que tu as pas été pris à on
aurait pour l'âme en paix tu es amis
parce que et tout a comme une espèce de
saine compétition réfère un peu malsaine
à l'école je pense qu' il dit tout le
temps que tu apprennes à l'école de
progresser de chemnitz nabab toute
supputation
c'est quand ça de l'école de tout le
temps été comme fait échouer vendredi à
l'école devant les profs
après si tu fais le club soda pour la
tournée de l'école fait déjà des salles
et
quand tu tombes des morts là devant
cette personne n'aille pas très classe
mais ergo ergo puis st lô entre ça m'a
aidé c'est un peu tout à ce que je dit
en entrevue le maire la première fois
que tu apprends dans ces colosses c'est
la relation thérapeutique humain loin
qui est établi avec la personne mais
sérieusement je pense pas que j'étais un
mauvais assez haut mais je t'ai de loin
pas les meilleurs de ma classe je
n'avais pas un bon ressenti au niveau
des meetings qui c'est super important
sauf que quand établi une bonne relation
thérapeutique et que le patient déjà eu
il ya une super confiance en tout cas
qui est plus détendue mais aussi quand
je jouais que le patient même effet le
sait lui que je chantais plus d'offres
que je me sentais bien fait quand
j'arrive en show même si les gens y en a
plein qui ne connaissent pas ou qui
m'ont vod plus qui ont aucune discussion
comme humeau mais j'ai six jeux car à
installer cette espèce de relation
thérapeutique avec une foule de grands
points
on a le goût de l'écouter lui tire
j'essaie chipeau chanceux d'avoir sujet
capable de faire ce ici jean une des
qualités que je capable d'avoir des
tables une relation rapidement je pense
que qu'il travaille mettaient quelque
chose d'un pays n'est là dedans
ouais c'est sûr qu'il ya une portion une
île qui m'est fait et une wiimote et
mettons secondaire des jeux un prout a
découvert ça sur le temps j'ai fait non
mais on seconde âgée fait le
spectacle n'ont même pas et on faisait
d'un gala de fin d'année l'un peu jean
herbert ouais mais tous les profs de
français les élèves dangereux en contre
j'ai fait ce que j'ai fait ici puis je
me rappelle je me frottais les
orienteurs et puis j'aurais vraiment
aimé se faire des petits personnages
plutôt qu'acheter revêt au cégep mais
juste un peu comique dans le classement
l'université mcgill il y avait le talent
show ça s'appelait pour amasser de
l'argent pour le bal de finissants de la
troisième année que il mourra en
première année j'ai fait j'ai appris ça
en français mais j'ai fait un numéro là
dessus j'avais réagi arrive à montréal
je prends le métro où tout le monde
parle anglais j'ai tellement francophone
gt300 les petits numéros qui teste vous
après huit minutes qui m'a déjà fait 26
la corde avec toi ou des villes arabes
mais c'était trop long après 15 minutes
est-ce que tu chantais que le monde est
en train de passagers quand même fait le
monde comprenne parce que s'ils parlent
un peu d'ergoter parle un peu du physio
piste mais ça reste c'était bien moi je
les écouterai je me trouverai des
grenats trois patinoires et c'est vrai
c'était quatre fois de 22 minutes et
quatre fois trop longue mais tu es un
bon 5 6 quand tu débutes là c'est ce qui
s'est passé cette foule stade c'est vrai
conseille à tout le monde j'ai vu que je
veux pas me dit pas si ces cas précis tu
arrives dans ta vie pitre un gala juste
pour rire ils te demandent six minutes
maximum 6 habitué à faire des vingt
minutes le pas bon pour tous oui c'est
jean-marc parallèle tout petit peu fort
ce que tu veux mais qui sait apprécier
la deuxième année je les fait la
troisième année je les animés pour notre
notre cohorte à nouveau notre balle j'ai
animé le nom le fashion show aussi vous
que je faisais des jobs îles de l'egée
eu la piqûre puis il y avait une fille
dans sa halle qui venaient me voir afin
de mon numéro la troisième année il ya
me dis tiens chan car on va donner la
carte d'un gérant lui montre un jeu l'a
appelé puis à fait
ouais ben moi je connais pas mais vient
ont fait un concours d'humour c'était un
bar qui fermait maintenant mais c'est le
peuple genre quartier on devait faire un
choix la botte c'est le soir qui ont
découvert eddy king
ce qui arrange
l'aem pop up qui a fait un one man show
des jeux et y avait une coupe du monde
restés qui était le neveu de la concours
puis me dis à tes bons mètres par
l'école soit les prix le cours
d'écriture le cours de présentation
numéro puis se passe la mécanique
d'écriture de l'humour le tc ça
s'apprend pas en 30 secondes
peux tu mets ton étudie les grands
comiques ou d'aller sur le fil
il ya du monde qui vont être très
mécanique technique qui apprennent
comment écrire lui mopi mes pauvres nous
je pense comme naturelle avec d'autres
l'autre con un histoire se passe dans ma
vie j'ai et wick un peu que ce soit plus
drôle mais le timing push et comment
bulletin en forme semble que
sérieusement c'est venu avec un joueur
perm pratiqua puis aussi parce que je
suis comme ça dans ma vie mais pendant
des années j'ai demandé pendant un bout
pendant un bout je parle avec des
humoristes fait j'en ai pas de procès du
moustique mon nom mais pour piquer comme
ben oui tu en sais juste que tu sais pas
que tu aimais m une règle de trouver
numération ce fait un renversement timps
et c'est finalement le punch et surtout
lui que la personne que tu te ramasses
mais je me rendais pas compte mais quand
après les procédés de ce fait au oui
mais moi j'écris pour un truc en faisant
il faudrait que je n'étais pas trop
intime parce que ce que j'ai ce que
j'avais analysé mettons de mon parcours
altéra tueur c'était que
la seule à faire que ça me donnait
maintenant on commente les mécaniques
d'un texte c'est si le texte passe pas
être capable de comprendre pourquoi moi
parce qu'un texte qui parce que
quelqu'un que jamais appris ces
mécaniques l'oeuvre capable d'écrire un
texte qui est excellent qui sait sauf
que si ça passe pas cette personne ne
connaît pas les mécaniques ou peut-être
pas comprendre pourquoi on est capable
d'analyser de l'intérieur qu'est ce qui
fait que ça fonctionne nous tester
c'était plus ce que je voyais mettons
dans la formation - le capable de dire
ok pourquoi ça marche pas c'est pourquoi
le texte marche papy d'être capable de
le reconstruire après ce n'est pas
nécessairement de l'écrire point il
était par exemple j'ai tué puis encore
le sais ce que je fais pas du stand up
en tant que tel mais jamais recevoir les
voir guillaume wagner ça me fait capoter
le niveau des quartiers un sujet
d'actualité ou décortiqué genre le
sarcasme s'il parle et mais je peux pas
forcer le menu mon grand père a fait une
maison ça c'est parti mais les guides
d'humour le numéro et sa comédie noble
vraiment
mais là persique puis on s'apprécie les
deux mathieu yamba glace c'est tellement
pas le site du mot que je fais qui lui
le comprennent
mais on se dit pas ce que je dis dans un
podcast je me dis que cette enquête
non mais si on m'avait écrit m
oui c'est ça
son numéro pis si j'aime beaucoup votre
stand up en fait je trouve sur l'humour
que je fais pas plus impressionné le
monde fait c'est fait non c'est pas
facile phare de la ville ont
sérieusement c'est que non je trippe sur
l'humour que je fais aussi de voir comme
un saint breton ou un jean marc simon
leblanc pour l'anecdote intéressant
j'aime ce c'est ce qui est certain c'est
que j'ai envie de pisser je consomme pas
énormément du monde mais je pense c'est
ce que kim au moins me rejoint le plus
ouais
l'anecdote on le rappelle people que
stein timide elle va regarder mais
j'avais trouvé ce crissement drôle
numéro qu'un fait au saguenay et les
aident à petit on numéro sûrement la
femme mais la moto mais je veux pas t'as
pas le choix d'adapter en même temps
après qu'il ait d'aucun 19 à 12 en
taillant exactement c'est juste que ce
filtre un peu plus parce que manger
quand je parle des fois les comme un sac
le qui s'entraînent deux places le c'est
sûr que tu fais vraiment tension qui tu
es mon show dure deux heures à ce moment
qu'il faut qui barrait sa une au 20 mai
45 minutes j'ai sélectionné des numéros
à lesquels les listings les plus clean
puis sow c'est juste que ce que ça fait
dans ce temps là quand tu es juste pas
de picsou
il utilise les 35 fois avec le christ à
sa place les bleus photo l'enlève des
numéros aussi exact les transitions le
tir parce que moi mon show c'est une
grosse geste je sais que mettons dans le
numéro de la police
ouais qui m'arrêtent en moto et est
menée jeudi
getac les policiers m'ont pas vu c'est
avec un peu de chance on deux policiers
centre-sud dans le chante mais cela je
peux pas de se demander qui des tacles
et je fais attaque les deux policiers
frenchy ahmeti le gag est pas là c'est
parce que la job plus tard c'est encore
le bas coût qui est les policiers ils y
prennent mon permis de conduire puis
avec moins de lundi 4 mai les faits puis
s'en vont l'aider dans le champ qu'est
ce qu'un peu de chances -moins mois avec
jean pendant ce temps là dessus mais le
ch et plus je me rends avec un peu de
chance mais aussi vont freiner les gags
marche plutôt compliqué la tâche en que
mon père me plaît ya pas de gags pendant
deux phrases depuis le service mais quid
stade appelé parce que j'ai fait ou si
une coupe d'écoles secondaires
maintenant je refuse qu'un c'est
secondaire 1 2 4 je prends des douches
des fondations sont capables mes charges
a fait paul jamais sérieusement si j'ai
sauf que ils comprennent plus de job
mais je crois qu'à cinq ans on faisait
des docks déflation nous way we be
serious sam alternance au début mais
j'ai réussi which he came les plus
jeunes mais secondaire 1 2 thaçi oui
toutes membres plus jeunes kavanagh
tessala cours d'eau des puissantes et
ouais surtout à cause de halle
mais ces mets ton et mais je sais pas si
avec aude et plus peut-être mais j'ai
rougi le plus beau look gens qui
disaient non pas tant parce que ce n'est
pas toute l'année puis je commence le
hyaric de ces jeunes cannois place à
l'une des faux sont au balcon tout pour
le cacher c'est que ça tombe et chris
pine un peu le jeu fait le
rabat 18 heures mettons qui sont une
bande de chiens inquiétude devant menant
à bois peluches pas de calais 11 h si le
snap tout le temps la mère ou le père et
qu'il paraît irresponsable qui t'a amené
cette plaie je parle avec les autres un
peu mais a fait mais j'ai une maman qui
m'a écrit tu sens qu'il y avait onze a
pas dit si les gens il ya tant poster
dans sa chambre chez humaine c'est
débile sont des gens il s'avérait que la
posture de la porte de la salle avec son
premier spectacle du mot est tellement
triste olympie il ya un petit gain de 11
ans qui fête son oral type de fin de
session des primaires small jeu comme
taberna qui vont ils vont se reconnaître
à certaines places puis surtout le petit
jeune que je pence et dans le show et
lui je parle là dessus je pose une
question jazdy plage quand j'entends un
numéro je t'aime objets well as mettons
antoine le moment des faits mais qu'ils
écoutent s'appelle qui s'appelle plus
antoine les jeunes les appels tout
arturo gabriel
mais à installer les visionnant le
georges notre ami appelle son enfant son
enquête georges
ouais ouais
douze ont parlé en parler de style des
noms d'enfants si jamais qui est rappelé
joseph joseph losey finances joe pinault
fait quand on est enfermé bastita mof ex
c'est sûr qu'un parti pascal enfin il ya
eu un mort a eu six enfants dont le nom
de ton fils de ton neveu si c'est sans
fin mais bons rails
il ya quatre enfants à lui puis sa
blonde avait deux de ses personnages
pour les gens qui écoutent ma fille
avait trois kid sable on avait deux qui
est important de rectifier fera qu il
côtoie pas complètement ok way fait
quatre mois que vous soutirer votre
podcast
mais sinon rien contre eux mais il ya
entre absolue mari mais y'a pas
d'appareil au riz non non le petit
jérémy un appareil chantepie mais c'est
quoi lui bon frag parle pas y'a pas sa
voix de jérémy sainte un hacker qui
n'inquiète pas de sens que ça il parle
pas non plus par dessus mais où moi je
le comprends mais temps j'ai grandi avec
du monde ça faisait deux fois deux voies
yates comprendrait quand il parle
mais bien sûr toujours été son témoin
oui ben non il est tombé sous la loge de
l'ennemi commun dans un gîte mais médias
50 le scmo fait pour moi j'étais sont
battus pour lui aussi la seule
surveillance et la brute du séchoir ce
qui est la pire affaire chacun qui ont
un fake le méfait que par le langage des
signes
[Musique]
moi je connais des mots le 6 mai
iti on se parle des milices super bien
sur mes lèvres puis mais je le comprends
qu'ils parlent facts cash comprend pas
peur on peut épeler le mot mais qu'ils
n'ont comme une expo à bien les deux
mais quand il parle avec sa blonde
remettons c'est comme un enfant calme
parce qu'il parle un langage un langage
des signes
rapidement puis salon n'est pas se sont
rencontrés à l'école d'etsaut
je viens comme et le clsm le centre de
loisirs de souris mus et du moral je
sais pas trop mais nightend 2 pour sow
belge en deuil c'est comme une
communauté c'est parce que je veux pas
c'est saddam comprends ta réalité
s'apprête à virer sur les blondes sur
d'affaires ouais ouais le les enfants
ils ont passé les quatre à lui non mais
les deux enfants de sa blonde oui en moi
et elle avait quelque chose dit elle
c'est résister elle est belle je sais
plus à combien la même année c'était les
64 dernier de sa famille était saoul et
ses parents sont sourds elle est sourde
ces enfants sont sourds qui se sait
dessus je dois ces statistiques laissent
et 100 % à 100 % de chances que ton
enfant chaussures ben non parce que là
mon frère qui est l'enfant qui ont hué
passe au hockey ses deux enfants après
la malédiction
ouais parce que parce que du côté de ton
frère s'est pris deux stars exacte a
figé
je ne sais pas comment ça fonctionne
pour sourcer héridis talent c'est parce
que mon face la méningite qui est moi
c'est ça qui a atteint comme l'est le
marteau puis les trop petit au losc mais
moi j'ai vu c'est normal que tu sais tu
mets ton que c'est quoi la condition est
restée en dedans surdité mais c'est
passé mais parce que pour moi c'est
comme
encore lisse mais pour raisons elles
sont super gentils ces enfants sont
tellement tellement sweet je sais pas si
tu es comme ils font tout en décalant
comme plutôt çi un peu gizem vraiment
beaucoup le pam a donc encore mais je
vois là bientôt tout et mon oncle il
faut nettement 4 enfin quand même toit
au début nous sommes t'avais dit qu' une
des choses que tu sais plus en huile et
mettons des personnes c'était devenu
même et s'écouter
souvent c'est vraiment si je les adore
mais c'est un bon moyen de contraception
le schéma sur wii les cartes sont
énervés parce que là tu restes là trois
heures c'est le fun c'est le fond de
cette fois mais quand tu t'envoles
sûrement shop silencieuse à proximité
des mosquées je trouve où le mettons
c'est là là parce que si j'y vois j'ai
votre temps en temps au niveau monde
veulent parce qu'il ya 10 à 16 ans il
joue dans le bantam james ivory ok mais
quand c'est noël tu as parlé deux filles
de la blonde mon frère parce qu'ils sont
super bien élevé les autres sont
bienvenu mais c'est la gratitude je
trouve que jean n'ont pas de citer les
dommages faits à la barre mon frère et
je sais pas si ça les orphelins mais
dont la les cadeaux qu'ils reçoivent des
soultes il a développé plus y attendent
d'en lâcher car c'est ok ok cool dit m
j'ai vécu une expérience comme celle là
quelques années ou est ce qu'il y avait
toutes les cousins cousines s'est fait
une grande famille élargie de petits
enfants placés
l'art band soulier l'eau des cadeaux
placé juste selon toulouse toulouse
toulouse
boyd au liner merci décourage aller au
prochain puis à une zone qui compte m
parce que le chasser de leur esprit la
valeur puis ambitieux mais ça c'est
témoin j'ai commencé maintenant cette
année à noël une joute dans nos familles
on fait juste un échange hockey etc tu
piges une personne un cadeau moi mais
moi j'ai fait deux ans que je donne
juste je fais à manger je donne de la
bouffe
ouais t'es à congeler ou parce que je
trouve que de donner mettons des
expériences comme étant des billets de
spectacles des shows des trucs éphémère
mais qui vont rester
je trouve que dans notre société je
trouve ça plus actuel
on dirait moi je suis plus à l'aise de
faire ce que maintenant mon neveu et ma
mère qui a donné un cadeau à aller voir
puisque lui aime danser
ouais ils sont allés voir le show de
nico archambault
ouais mais bon un show de lui pour
montrer un gars qui donnent ce type
puis sont allés voir un spectacle sur
tel cadeau tu puisses je trouve c'est
vraiment cool parce que du matériel
d'aidé qu'hadopi 2 pas être contente de
découvrir d'oublier de sud qui dégoûte
qui te le donne et ça me décourage
vraiment beaucoup d'acheteurs crocs nico
archambault parce que moi je les
rencontre et j'ai fait les dieux de la
danse un pakistanais avec corinne côté
acquis qui était enceinte
je l'avais pas dit le psy qui est
d'allumer routes avait baissé malgré la
répétition s'est écoulé 9 7 mois plus
tôt l'échappée à terre un peu de tout
mais c'était vraiment si c'est qu'il y
avait beaucoup de leurs huit ans y avait
déjà levé plus chi minh et ce au moment
où on peut apprécier le show fini seppi
a couru sur une plate forme de quatre
pieds de haut pas sauter le mot japanime
est en simple est ce moi - fiq système
et après quand l'annoncé goethe est
enceinte pendant nous répète ce secteur
a capoté chez faire capoter
mais nicolas charbonneau
nous a bien confirmé qu'on était
mauvaise en soi mais ayant coupé en fait
au montage nico archambault je pense des
juristes comme méchants sont évidemment
c'est pour rire si vous invitez on n'est
pas mon genre venait pas et d'écarter
forget avait aucun rythme mais ce
n'était pas bon faut faire les grands
ballets via jamais vu en danse jeux qui
y avait un post sur facebook derrière
massa georges jourde là que je les
rencontre une coupe de foie d'oie qui
sortit duda cousquer vegan tapie est
super cool c'est vraiment un gars rien à
dire de nérac
il s'est fait toute sa carrière dans
l'eau qui s'est battu la gauche aux
points sa gueule déjà un fils de
commotions cérébrales et la justice ait
jamais été non car le métier puis idia
seule fois où est ce que je me souhaite
maintenant que c'était
cette fois le pilote se regarde la vidéo
ben ce genre ce qui est en soi une fille
puis ailleurs sur un patin et la fed
s'attend à tout et on a droit aux bleus
la seule chose que c'était quand même
surpassé à ta carrière un bâton puis la
fois que tu peux maintenant 46 après la
conception tout à fait ici par un peu si
je comprends bien ouais pas dans la
création
j'ai fait moi j'y joue au quai pendant
neuf ans j'ai mené pendant l'été le
tiche j'étais tout le temps si on a une
piscine au coin de chez nous et j'ai
trois piscines municipales ppim on y
passe un club de water polo de trigance
à jouer le mais j'aime ça parce que je
joue avec mon grand cousin bonne
accroche au mur
je sais je le fais tout le temps je t'ai
fit le lit pas niabaly me faisait pas
bon dans certains lots fort riche désert
y avait des bourses pour les meilleurs
comptable je t'ai tomber troisième
meilleur compteur de la ligue 1 parce
que c'était justement de l'eau fut moi
je l'appelle mon coach paul hallmark
brunette que je salue qui est encore
mais excellent ami aujourd'hui que je
vous rejoins une fois semaine qui m il
me dit ah on va pas donner la bourse en
argent mais cech en inde il sait que ça
vaut rien coûté pour jouer dans le club
de water polo
finalement j'ai commencé à jouer entre
paulo puis je faisais un peu la même
technique le titre de l'eau fait pas mal
à la saison pirelli règles qui empêchent
de face
ben oui mais quand tu es jeune tu j'ai
commencé à 12 après la guerre après
seulement douze ans jusqu'en 7 à 10 ans
- parce que bref qui j'ai demandé de fil
en aiguille c'est un fait qui est mon
pass bélisle c'est toujours votre polo 3
4 semaines puis décide jour entre paulo
la partie de la cellule je me suis
entraîné et puis on s'entraînait les
tout on avait trois matins par semaine
c'est que j'allais m'entraîner avant
l'école ajouté pep jetant chez la cause
du sujet puis le lit tournoi bhl j'ai
fait des championnats canadiens
ce jeudi dans le podcast pour ses crimes
par le tissu ou non non résidents les
mains la ph
ah oui c'est ça c'est quelqu'un qui est
arrivé au cégep
il a un jour autre paulo puis il y avait
le club de natation du cégep de
saint-hyacinthe les lauréats et ils
m'ont demandé que non ok mais moi même
tâche est content je m'entraîne donner
un maillot un sac
le challenge est la marge de lille
aurait préféré un speedo il ya de plus
pratique pour porter les vents et c'est
là que tu te rends compte que mon âge
crissement mal et johan blot le temps
est vraiment si on est bon comme tout
des appris de ce que je faisais puis
s'émeut j'ai d'abord à flipper ou
surprise mais ils sont rendus compte que
les chèques crissement rappelle oddo
parce que au polo et une offre le temps
aux au point pour la balle sans vie
comme un pied en défense que j'apprends
la compétition s était à sherbrooke
je suis parti pis comme une [ __ ] métier
même pas essoufflé
c'est que juste et au dos puis j'étais
vraiment le roi et déjà déjà mais huit
tirs les petits travaux la distance qui
diffusait je pense c'est 100 m le type
c'était une piscine de 50 mètres julien
garroy - c'est ça qui sait qu'il ya des
flag au milieu de ces limogeages un
excellent milieu de la longueur je
pensais que c'était les flaques de
certains clips sur pas le cacher au
milieu puis j'avais jamais dans la
légende de coup droit je vais retourner
le jeu vous le meur manqué qu'un filet
de retour j'ai dit à ma première course
au dos j'ai été disqualifié qui mais
j'ai fini par me classer
pour les championnats dessus parce que
tu pensais comme trois quatre courses le
dans différents cégeps est prête pour
aller au championnat puis jetés par les
tutus et nager collégiale ouais j'avais
décide pas y aller parce que j'étais
trop important pour moi de pâma chimie
organique puis d'étudier puis jean
grosset beaucoup avec l'école un lieu
que j'avais dit je m'en tape un peu du
club puis en n'étant pas aller ne va pas
l'arranger de cégeps ça va bien insulté
le coach puis surtout l'organisateur
puis réseau tila march et de n'est pas
n'importe qui a inspiré à luz la hâte
que tout est donc énorme et c'est du
monument vraiment a traversé une forêt
leurs trousses il aimait ma vie écrit
j'avais été banni à vie du club de
natation de saint-hyacinthe était venu
de profiter d'un loupé toutes seules nos
entraînements blabla et n'était pas
prête aux championnats c'est hype faut
que je continue à jouer au polo
puis j'ai jamais pour le club sinon j'ai
collégiale et nathan ouais mais cette
compétition importante à l'intention car
c'est cet avis ok on vient te payer
l'équivalent de 4000 wallace ouais
cette année une carrière des sprinteurs
au dos on ne sent comme un problème en
gir avec tout sur une boîte de
participants à bastia presse mais j'ai
tout tenté coéquipiers sur l'eshop
distance le petit tu manques et les
mises au jeu le tout lors que j'ai joué
au pouvoir qui en avait dans le rouge
ont amené il ya un gars qui faisaient du
polo s'appelait françois deschamps
mais si les gays y vient du polonais
jamais danger de sa vie vraiment par le
pôle le meilleur jour spéciaux et puis
tu sais il y était drôle tout le monde
voyait qu'il faisait pour lutter quoi
qu'il se passe à peu près la même chose
alors qu'il est vraiment vite non je
peux le club de sainte-foy
puis rapidement aux 50 gr de longueuil
était vite en tête et là c'est la preuve
qu'ils pouvaient dans gmail et évitent
en quart avec une technique un peu tout
croche mais il est évident qu'ils
amenaient dalphond à chaque année car
déçus circuit universitaire pour te
fasses un temps pour traquer les
ouailles pour les championnats canadiens
pis c'est comme quand tu fais ce sens
dans le ccal parce que tu sais quand
votre dépenses payées aux curieux
canadiens peu importe
puis la fois où est ce que lui il fait
son stand anti georges peut-être de sa
cinquième compétition à vis de notation
les prêts sont cependant appréciable au
canadien ils montrent histoire de l'eau
et monte sur le bloc
bref un backflip d'ampsin pas tellement
qu'ils étaient congrès métaux pas le
droit de faire ce temps que l'arbitré
comme disqualification le genre tonte en
compote et disqualifié man après la
course maintenant mais sa
disqualification csn enlève sa course le
jury qualifié mais ne pourra faire ce
que demandent les couches du rjr est
allé contester la décision si c'était la
grosse affaire de joie de panneaux les
connais aucune qualification pour les
ide cinq fois mais il y avait un bon
twitch d'éviter azpitik quand tu fais du
water polo un certain niveau
j'imagine que l'agressivité tout le
temps max pid
il faut que ce soit bon parce que la
musique sinon j'ai plus fait du combat
mais la rapidité l'est surtout sur ses
comme la mise au jeu puis une fois que
tu as la tactique bacs le 20 mai à la
taxe et comme les positions le24 était
comme une demi lune
les deux jeux savant lapointe c'est le
chiffre de 5000 doigt certaines
personnes voient les drivers ou qu'ils y
aillent plus vite qu'elle garde devant
la défense
c'est comme une femme d'un bar par
flippant on double le groupe legault
s'entraînent passent généralement en
photo mais bref
sébastien jeu de rapidité mais surtout
de grosses endurance gt gt coup et
justement c'est ma façon de faire début
tout
ma carrière de water polo se maintenant
j'ai vite parce que one on one mettant
quelqu'un sur mon dos je n'avais pas si
bonnes jambes
les faits ici encore plus raide
progressif aux troyens laisse pas de
fausses croyances parce que oui c'est
vrai mais quand même c'est sous cet
angle s'il ya le moindre en quelqu'un
qu'ils aillent larbi de passe au début
le big bang le public présent moi je
sais juste qu'il fut un temps dans army
début moi j'ai jamais fait ça mais le
monde il se couper les ongles en biseau
tu gagnes c'est un des sports les plus
rome et noir et palois est vrai maroufle
ouais mais j'ai bien j'ai vu j'ai vu des
chars d'assaut le givre oui j'ai vu un
gars parce qu'une fois que tu as fait un
but la mise au jeu et au centre on est
face à face mais c'est l'équipe que le
ballon la donne en arrière mais était
quand même les six gosses en place en
ligue 1 face à l'audi gimont capitaine
au prix les nerfs du casque de l'autre
les lethenet parlement gâtés comme des
armures elle a su cela parce qu'il ya
des ziani loupé du toit c'est comme
juste une boucle y apprit la boue puis à
driver trail shot d'en face on aurait eu
sa
la route est jamais vu ce bel arbitres
et tout le monde le sait il son panier
tout le match quelqu'un lui at il tué le
match est déjà perdu notre bon vieux os
non mais ça tu te fais poursuivre la
belle surprise pour ses qualités j'ai vu
ottawa comme d'aidé au lapd et des
hausses étaient reconnus pour aider à
ces violences qui leur désormais moins
bien rigolé on le subit et est placé
dans l'équipe parce qu'à des problèmes
de violence à l'école puis on trouvait
que la police la même façon de façon
legging mailloux et si le barça mais il
ya cassé l'os
à l'âge où l'un le maxillaire la casse
est sur le grill sart tilman lien peut
pas payer passés à l'hôpital cinq ans
parce que monsieur tout le monde qui me
dit paulo le seuil est lourd à la focale
ou encore pierre alaux ça fait mal aussi
une un coup de coude cantine on jouait
donc quelqu'un pense oui ou cantinage
mettant le la défense et et tour
d'autres le tout ce temps vient passer
de passer il faut que je passe ses
jambes mais j'ai vu des gosses faire
craquer découpé dans face extérieure à
contre-courant de son coup de pied dans
la face à ses conséquences et les de la
façade feutre questionné sur pourquoi tu
fais ce sport oui mais que j'ai pas
besoin de ça dans ma vie dans le fond
bien moi je thérapie sous le sort se
joue un jeu driver pas pressé de jouer
c'est sûr le camarade au km longe un peu
le même jeu que j'ai juste appris c'est
que j'ai pas réinventer la technique le
sait quelqu'un me dise fascinant ce
tournoi c'est que je drive et du 4 mars
assez rare que le monde peut se passer
pas vraiment dingue mais je drive aux
quatre matchs passés devant le centre
c'était ma façon hameau de jours pour
l'eau sans nom était allé faire dans le
fond on avait de nos amis qui habitent à
baie-saint-paul tab et saint-paul
faisons un tournoi de polo une fois par
année qui a mené notre ami fait on a
l'espoir dont on va aller se faire une
équipe et on va aller la botte et tout
dégât du rouge en natation aux tirs de
loin les plus vieux de la piscine est
vite c'est rien ça donnait rien
là ça me donnait rien du tout il était
la seule à faire que ça me donnait
bateau s'est jetée capable de tourner
sur le dos bhl http que personne ne me
rattrape attraper la balle tu tournes
comme pas de lancer une meilleure jamais
jouer avec un ballon
le nom avec la balance puis après sur la
minute que tu réalises comment ça se
joue vraiment le polo patrie trois fois
vers le fond la piscine structure des
coûts d'un côté je me rappelle la soirée
après premièrement notre équipe était
misérable mais la soirée à pression là
comme on a décidé rester à
baie-saint-paul boire la bière parler on
est est défoncée genre à 10 ans la télé
chez peat et le lendemain tu te
réveilles tu sais quand tu te
débrouilles tabanac regarder respirer du
côté droit le défilé des rêves et
dernier tournoi que j'ai fait les joué
pour l'université sherbrooke parce que
des amis tels appuis mais je vais y
avait pas de club mais guy le titre que
j'ai joué pour les autres qui dernier
tournoi je me rappelle avoir joué
j'avais les deux bras engourdi à fin du
tournoi
j'avais tellement mal au cou depuis tout
petit et léger qui ont joué comme des
trois matchs par jour parce que la
fonction des concentrés ce vendredi sans
dimanche afin jetez plus capable chanter
puis mais je peux plus jouer il faut qu
on avait joué contre les hydres
justement en italie il s'appelait jeunes
mais ils étaient énormes
il lui a joué pour l'équipe qui chutent
tu parles pays était coach après désir
ouais c'est ça si je dors ligue 1 est en
niveau olympique polonais c'est des
animaux - sesia baril semble énorme
c'est jean rainville wacip y sont sont
des gros gags des mains et l'impression
d'aller voir et on les avait battus et
si c'était leur deuxième était là on
n'avait jamais joué ouais mais on avait
dans notre équipe
à ce moment là on avait dû aux cantons
parce que son père lui joey de jouer et
lausanne et à matadi olympique en
polonais natation 1,17 sur l'équipe
nationale de water polo puis lui
toujours c'est un enjeu trop tard en
turquie était vraiment vite
sauf qu'il ya toujours appris à jouer le
ballon faites lui mettons il se
démarquait puis lui avait dit qu'on
n'était pas si t'es pas l'équipe au
désir dit-il lui se met à l'avant puis
lui de garde de ce camp mais c'est pas
tout le monde qui a pas de l'ancien
baron à la fin des combats c'est
tellement atalante et émis le souhait
goût de déjà vu les jeux mondiaux de
montréal en 2005 j'avais genre en 2005
j'avais 14 ans 13/01/2009 dans l'es14
moi j'avais 21
nick et moi qui ait ce genre et demi en
huitièmes qui était bénévole aussi là
bas on était allé voir le match final
qui était serbie-monténégro contre la
birmanie je pense si sa c2 n'ont pas de
nom mais ces deux pays en guerre aussi
l'impact mais on y avait des policiers
d'un stand qui mène c'était d'une
violence incroyable ça m'a aidé c'est
que l'équipe avait australie aux autres
qui avaient fini troisièmes ou
quatrièmes et et nous devons la chasse à
côté des groupies juste voir les gauches
mais j'suis pas de temps jamais dans ma
vie j'aurais pu jouer ce niveau là
c'était dessus des pays qui ne se leurre
pas comme nationale je sais pas c'est
l'ancien finale j'imagine c'est ouais
mais c'est plus important que huawei
canada que je pense qu'on sait jamais
patate une année vous allez les filles
les filles sont bonnes en 2008 je pense
que les guetter leur ouais si je marque
au quart de finale probablement mais je
sais je sais quelle année qu'on a réussi
à se rendre mais mais les filles ont
toujours été très bonne j'étais souvent
états unis
kadhafi n'en sait pour allemand béton
le sport le plus je passais serait
violent mais violence est le sport le
plus rough mettons pour le corps ouais
ça pis le rugby ouais c'est moi le rugby
le masseur match à rejouer pour le vert
& or de sherbrooke o a dit bill puis
tant qu'à revenir jouer contre le rouge
et or premièrement rouge et or c'est au
québec sont seuls dans leur ligue les
feuilles de rugby c'est ma soeur avait
perdu comme 5 0 mais je me rappelle
l'image vie d'une fille du rouge et or
qui arrive sur le side line le nez cassé
qui cingle a pas pleine gueule de sanaa
le lapsus aligné comme un médecin où je
suppose testé qui de l'équipe un staff
médical par le nez 14la fait artaud à ce
métier sont nés de même un peu assommés
deux affaires dans nip et retourne jouer
ouais genre si c'est comment une école
c'est rock et claque leur place
ok pilote du 100 ma soeur son gilet du
vert et or étaient couverts de sable
rouge à ces métiers c'est dégueulasse
est un sport qui se joue pas c'est
comment c'est accepter que vous avez pas
d'équipement est pas grave montrez-vous
dedans en pleine course non sans fin à
ces rohff le rugby lé mais oui en terme
de baisse un vieux vieux vieux sondages
je suis pas comme il l'entend s'arrêter
sa red bull water polo les deux par les
programmes le j'avais dit ça sous écoute
piment quoi le dit mais je pense que les
mms et n'ont jamais jamais trompé tous
titrés plus par le combo honnêtement
jamais compris le tpiy moule genre j'ai
mal pour un autre sport de combat
mais je ne dirai pas non au calme c'est
en forgeant même les non cartés ce que
gm jambes au one one je suis tombé raide
à toi moi c'est parce que j'aime ton
j'aime les combats plus comme la boxe
olympique mettons ou excuse le bord du
monde n'aime pas ça quand ça sera
jusqu'à la fin des jeux dont floyd
mayweather le ticket - jamais regardé
parce que kaki ce boys ya personne qui
le touchent jamais si pluie pas assez
fort pour moi qui ait quelqu'un me score
des points c'est moi j'aime ça regardez
ce sauf que de voir ces comprend caspar
de combat c'est vraiment de là
la stratégie dans ce sens qui est dit à
un humain devant toi puis lequel un
grand fracas mange appelation la porte
c'est vraiment comme un espèce de joie
l'était c'est sa vie mais n'a basculé en
tabarnak
ça arrive souvent qu'on pense les teens
autant elle me parlait beaucoup la donne
et stevenson au québec parce que c'est
arrivé à québec
oui je suis un québécois est arrivé à
québec mais ces légumes et on les lit
mexicaine qui seront amenés ici pour
faire les combats préliminaires quand
personne écoute le c'est juste pour
entretenir la croix de ses pièces rock
en stand by le 6 1 à 4 dans le premier
combat il met un deuxième combat dessus
parce que les autres ont séduit la dh
mais s'il ya pas de ma carte d autres se
battent pour y fixer du monde sont comme
stand by pour venir cette haine l'étude
et le monde comme ceux qui reviennent
chez eux mais depuis que les ferrures
gens sont plus la même personne besoin
de forcer pour payer pour leurs familles
parce que tu sais il ya beaucoup de nos
fils battre parce qu'on vient ici on ne
se bat pas ce qu'ils peuvent rien faire
notre offre qui captent arrive pile se
fait tabasser situe dans le vestiaire
adonis stevenson apparemment qui aurait
pris sa douche clear sortie de la douche
plier comme tomber mais tim haines une
commotion ça c'est les effets peuvent
arriver après vraiment des mets ton
quand tu te couches plus tu te relèves
pilote et le thé ghosn le tien fait que
le monde
ils viennent se battent à brécey
retournent chez eux ils étaient déjà
mexico même prêt arrive dans la famille
tombe plus appréciés à 40 ans ils sont
car à des souvenirs de ses séquelles on
le sait de plus en plus c'est quoi les
effets de commerce et un montant en cash
montgueux la donne bref si le deal à
roybon vos combattants
georges st pierre est en train d'essayer
de vous expliquer tilt et puis le tram
ans à 40 ans puis sessegnon est prêt il
ya des mots avec cinq ans qui viennent
et comme il ya
les blind side ont pu tolérer cela
fallait parce que c'est justement il ya
du monde professionnel
c'est une business puisque un sport
réglementée et j'aime mieux voir des
bauges rapide et des trucs avec finesse
qui s'éclate et c'est là il ya beaucoup
de monde mais ton football en ce moment
qui chialent parce que les corps arrière
sont protégés beaucoup parce que comme
tu as pu le droit des plaques et quand
le ballon est parti c'est la ligne est
vraiment moche ouais mais mais en même
temps c'était un plaquage qui laissait
sans réaction ça sert plus à rien pettis
d'élèves les plaquages plus nécessaire
oui le chiot pour le gueut dans son
salon qui veut voir du monde se faire
rentrer dedans il est moins bon mais en
même temps tu vas avoir des athlètes
meilleurs plus longtemps ouais t'es fixé
juste le sport en général donc le show
est ce qu'on a vraiment besoin de voir
du monde se faire dès qu'il est dans
tous les coeurs
on a perdu des vieux souvenirs est même
passé des mois et s'est réveillée métier
comme
c'est le même principe avec michael
schumacher
ouais t'es qu'un qu'il faut qu'ils aient
des situations comme ça d'habitude ça
reste plus à l'inter ne s'en sort pas
tant que apparemment que s'est réveillée
mais d'autres encore tu es dans un état
pitoyable c'est comme chez macquarie
légumes
c'est sûr que c'est la raison pour
laquelle on n'entend pas parler de ces
comme l'a fait un accident de ski
le hockey il ya deux mois plus tard la
personne qui remet ancien son nom et le
canton cherche sur internet 3g si vous
chercher pour schumacher s'est hissée
réveiller un puisque tu sais entre les
branches c'est que y est ils répondent
plus à son nom pitié c'est parce que
premièrement c'est pas le souvenir que
tu veux
c'est que maintenant son entourage le
monde heil si tu vois ma coach manioc
arrivé en chaise roulante qui ça c'est
la dernière image que te voir de lui
alors que l'image qu'on a maintenant
c'est lui qui chante du monde meilleur
pour six mois avec ses salles bierhoff
un autre exemple de carbone oui c'est
sûr je la raclée lui qui conduit tu
trompes l'alléchante la victime d'un
accident de ski à masquer que ton fils
dans un sous bois
comme le personnage soit je ne suis un
c'est ça mais le même principe
par respect pour l'entourage et où je
pense qu'il ya des lessives en scène sa
mort est un peu jusqu à preuve ce qu'on
va pas revenir dessus mais les revenants
comme a provoqué tueur mais pas de suite
non sinon je crois qu'ils aillent voir
un ergot de chaussures d'armes étaient
choqués oui mais en fait ça s'est
vraiment bien comme je sais plus les
dates qui sont au top mais quelques
baguettes et bon pied
mais viendra le show de 45 minutes si
vous voulez la version non censurée au
soir
[Rires]
que non mais oui les spectacles puis tg
je commence le 5 février en fait c'est
de faire les pros partir pat groulx moi
c'est quand même c'est wild side de
ferraille et ergothérapeutes ostéopathe
je fais de l'humour puis le semo patte
gauche tripes et tu peux pas dire quand
j'étais petit je me suis rendu compte
que nos ventes différence avec respect
quand même de ceux ci et les grues luxe
et au luxe et au niveau des grottes
c'était dessus les personnels ont bien
ri chanté c'est le polype chabot s'est
passé mike roy dupuis taran diallo en
raison des personnages différents achats
ce qui s'appelait c'est juste pour lippi
chabot il faisait des solos de mêlée
d'algues au luxe luxury tax à sylviane
puis il faisait musiqueplus ouais il a
tout pour lui en effet que j'entends ça
elle est belle on au club soda le hockey
leucate et brillant prix voyons comment
après ça
la première médiatique à
l'avant-première c'est le monde
cherchait c'était un puits sans fond
comment cela va partir de là on va faire
la tournée du québec et je pense qu
grâce par des petites salles quand même
bien on fait enfin à fait c'est je crois
pas car pour l'instant c'est les énormes
salle c'est comme albert rousseau les
pires mais on fait comme le grand
théâtre qui était sale temps des belles
dates de ce deal avec lui causerait cool
qui est moins bon des gazelles fans
m'ont dit je souhaite une bonne année
par image haute et s je souhaite des
baumettes que des coquilles elle même à
des modèles y aurait une foule à west
bay
[Musique]